gut dann begrüße ich sie zur heutigen
sitzung heute gehen wir jetzt zunächst
in diesem text den ich ihnen rom
geschickt hatte hatte jeder von ihnen
neben einer e-mail bekommen ein
kommilitone hat sie nicht bekommen
wer sie sonst nicht bekommen hat kann
noch mal schauen der liste ob sein
die dadurch geht ob sein name richtig
eingetragen ist ob die e mail richtig
ist ich sage zu beginn noch was was
jetzt schon mitbekommen haben nämlich
meine digitale begleitung dieses
seminares also ich habe eben seit zwei
jahren so ein bisschen digitale projekte
durchgeführt und auch in diesem seminar
soll so eine anbindung stattfinden an
ein youtube kanal
sie haben sie vielleicht schon das video
gesehen also die die seminar philo cast
sind die zwei namen der kanäle die ich
habe und ich zeige ihnen gleich mal kurz
noch ein bisschen was näheres über
diesen zweiten kanals vielleicht ein
bisschen laut die lautstärke muss ich
noch ein bisschen reduzieren
wir schauen uns gleich noch ein film an
den kleinen also fast
gehen sie mal auf youtube und gehen sie
mal einen philo ist dann finden sie main
kanal ich weiß nicht wer von ihnen hat
dieses video schon gesehen über
hausarbeiten schreiben haben das ja also
ich glaube dass ich da alles gesagt habe
was man zu hause arbeiten sagen kann wie
man sie schreiben soll schauen sich das
nochmal an hat recht guten anklang
gefunden also leitfrage und so weiter
und so fort dasselbe gilt natürlich auch
für s ich glaube ich habe auch noch so
ein merkblatt rom geschickt hat jeder
von ihnen sein heck bekommen also
einiges das selbsterklärend die einzige
frage die noch offen ist es die wann die
einzelnen termine sind für die
jeweiligen es
und ich habe es jetzt so gemacht dass
ich ihr vom ende her gekommen bin ich
habe sich also den letzten es den
vierten müssen sie an diesem termin
abgeben ist irgendwann im september ich
habe das auf dieses blatt geschrieben
ich stehe auch noch mal alles aufs lsf
system also bis dahin müssen sie einfach
ihren vierten se abgegeben haben
so einfach ist es nicht wenn sie nicht
abgeben
schwierig und eine weitere bedingung
gibt es noch sie sollten zwei essays
über ein historisches thema schreiben
und zwei über aktuellere texte also 2 1
zb über die e-card ein überblick über
montani vielleicht über nietzsche haben
wir jetzt nicht hier im seminar
aufgenommen aber auch der hat
interessantes über tiere gesagt oder sie
schreiben noch ein über david hume was
dir über tiere gesagt hat man da gibt es
also durchaus viele anknüpfungspunkte
und zwei es sollten sie schreiben über
modernere lenkerinnen und lenker die was
über das thema tier gesagt haben
und da haben sie ja auch eine große
auswahl in der digitalen text sammlung
die sie bereits sich bestimmt
heruntergeladen haben oder schon
ausgedruckt haben diese auch im sap
system finden also schauen sie mal
vorbei hier bei philo cast ich gebe hier
auch mal noch ein paar flyer herum
können sich gerne eins nehmen dass es
also ein projekt das von der eu
gefördert wird ein offizielles projekt
und ich freue mich über jeden weiteren
abonnenten weitere sendungen sind
geplant am samstag wurden fünf weitere
sendungen aufgenommen hier im studio
nebenan und eine sendung wird auch noch
zum thema geistert ihre es eben sein
also wird diesem thema gewidmet sein
das wird wahrscheinlich in der nächsten
woche gedreht
ich sagte ja auch schon gleich es gibt
noch eine app dazu wie können sich
herunterladen viel oka step und hier
sehen sie auch es gibt
gewisse als ich werde ab und zu so
freiwilligen tests machen die können sie
ausprobieren oder nicht das sind so
multiple choice tests sie bekommen
danach eine automatische auswertung also
wenn sie so ein bisschen mein
wissensstand zu überprüfen wollen haben
sie dazu in diesem semester mehrmals die
gelegenheit zwar irgendwo hier eine
meldung ja können müssen sie nicht also
ich bin da sehr liberal die gefahr ist
nur die das muss ich dazu sagen wenn sie
alle vier es sofort abgeben kann es sein
dass sie vier mal dieselben probleme
drin haben und ich dann sage gut da
wurde das nicht berücksichtigt da nicht
da nicht da nicht viermal und dann haben
sie eben nichts gelernt also sagen wir
sie haben den vorteil werden sie es
früher abgeben ich kann ihn auch noch so
richtwerte nennen also vier richtwerte
können sich selbst abgeben wenn sie es
nicht machen wollen ist ihre sache
sie laufen gefahr dass sie eben sich
nicht verbessern im laufe des dass sie
haben andernfalls also sondern weil sie
haben dann die möglichkeit eben immer
eine rückmeldung von mir zu bekommen
sind ganz hinten fragen in der letzten
reihe ich bemerke eine leichte unruhe
gibt es fragen die für alle von
interesse sind falls nicht würde ich
nochmal wie ich schon sagte sie können
sich zwei historische themen auswählen
sie müssen sich zwei historische themen
auswählen und sie müssen sich zwei
neuere themen aus was die da bin ich
liberal ich gebe was an ich kann ihm da
mögliche themen geben aber es ist ein
sehr freies format was davon lebt dass
man selbst sich einbringt ich komme da
gern entgegen ich kann ihn
themenvorschläge machen wobei der dann
auch einfach nur so lauten würden david
hume über das tier wäre ein sl thema
natürlich sollten sie nicht nur dann
wieder geben was david hume gesagt hat
sondern wie ich jetzt in diesem
rund mail bereits geschrieben habe und
wie ich in der letzten sitzung gesagt
hatte sie sollten pointiert sich ein
leih problem vornehmen und das ist
natürlich nicht bezeichnet mit david
hume über das tier das ist kein leid
problem das ist einfach nur so eine
generelle angaben so können sie den scb
titel oder so können sie das thema
wählen
aber natürlich gilt auch für ein essay
dass sie einen pointierten titel wählen
also auch die titel finden ist nicht
unterschätzen titel montiert heißt
zugespitzt also durchaus konzentration
auf ein problem perspektiven dieses
allgemein themas unter einer ganz
speziellen sichtweise dass sie das ganze
mal umkehren sollen was interessantes
herausbekommen und interessant ist
durchaus auch wenn sie sagen was hat der
video da geschrieben aber noch
interessanter ist es wenn sie das was
sie wie die umgeschrieben haben
problematisieren oder unter einer ganz
bestimmten leitfrage perspektiven das
ist ein essen leitfrage leib problem
beim sc auch ganz wichtig wie bei einer
hausarbeit
wir kommen dann noch drauf also wenn sie
gut aufpassen also die der vorteil der
regelmäßigen teilnahme mit diesem
seminar ist der dass sie immer mal
wieder von mir einen tipp bekommen
worüber sie ein gutes es einen guten se
schreiben könnten oder eine gute
hausarbeit ich glaube ich habe im
letzten sinn ist in der letzten stunde
schon mal was gesagt ich werde immer
wieder einfließen lassen wenn sie dann
hier sind haben sie den vorteil
ok dann schreibe ich mir das auch
darüber könnte ich jetzt ein essay
schreiben also mein tipp wäre
schreiben sie die vier essays verteilt
im semester ich werde auch noch so ein
paar mögliche abgabetermine umgeben aber
das sind nicht verpflichten wenn sie es
nicht schaffen wenn sie alle gesammelt
abgeben wollen können sie das gerne tun
diese app wie gesagt ja bitte
ja genau
also ich bekomme ja heute noch auf einen
text zu sprechen und in diesem text wird
thomas nägel auch genannt wenn sie es
lesen haben und ich werde auch noch eine
literaturliste herumschicken mit
sekundärliteratur und auch mit neueren
titeln es gibt also sehr interessante
neuerscheinungen zu diesem thema
das kommt noch die zimmer ja noch in der
ersten sitzung genau diese app gibt es
noch gewisse und jetzt gibt es den affen
coco den affen kennt ihn niemand von
ihnen kennt von ihnen jemand coco den
affen nicht mache ein bisschen leise ich
hoffe nicht dass es so laut ist schauen
wir ob das funktioniert ich mache ein
bisschen leise ich befürchte dass es zu
laut ist coco den affen kennt ihn
niemand von ihnen ja bitte da ja genau
haben sie das dem text entnommen der
heutigen sitzung oder wussten sie so
genau also die frage ist jetzt die
können tiere sprechen
und jetzt schauen wir uns doch mal einen
film an ich hoffe ist lang
[Musik]
ist der ton laut genug soll ich ein
bisschen lauter machen daraus ein
bisschen lauter
rom errichtet auch hier ist die
tonqualität
naja ok ist übersteuert okay maries da
wieder ein bisschen hoch sie haben die
einleitung gehört kann man es gut sehen
geht es einigermaßen jahr ist der held
dann müssen wir das hier noch ein
bisschen irgendwie überziehen
ich weiß nicht wie das geht
vielleicht kann man jetzt auch so machen
so also schauen sie sich mal diesen film
jetzt an der geht nicht so lang der geht
jetzt noch vier minuten unter dem
gesichtspunkt unter der leitfrage haben
tiere eine sprache oder hat hat coco
hat coco eine sprache und die genauere
frage ist dann die uhr an können wir das
erkennen gegebenenfalls
hmm
ok jetzt hoffe ich dass die tonqualität
gut ist sonst mache ich ein bisschen
lauter trend is your friend and the
fashion week sei der kranke sich stetig
entwickelt wird
[Musik]
eine
denn
im internet
[Musik]
die herren
ein wenig scheint das tut not denn nicht
jedes 10
[Musik]
ja so viel zum affen sind ihnen
besonders auffällige wendungen noch im
bewusstsein nachdem sie jetzt diesen
winkel ziehen haben wir sind zwei sehr
sehr interessante passagen hier aus
diesem film noch aufgefallen
vielleicht haben sie auch was besonders
in erinnerung behalten neben dieser
frage jetzt die wir folgen erklären
wollen
haben sie da irgendwelche setzte noch in
erinnerung
genau das war dieses windows dieses
fenster in mind wurde glaube ich gesagt
das bewusstsein oder den geist wie wir
ihn übersetzen ein fenster als es öffnet
sich was wir haben eine piste mission
zugang zu diesem fremd psychisch etwas
fremd psychisches wir haben eine psyche
wie haben seelische vorgänger und dieses
tier coco der affe hat etwas seelisches
den sich und diese sprache ist also
metaphorisch gesehen das fenster mit dem
wir zugang zu dem fremd psychischen
erhalten haben sie noch eine weitere
passage weitere wendung aus diesem
kurzfilm in erinnerung behalten die
denkwürdig ist in ihren augen
also ich hatte noch was das war dieser
exchange diese intellectual exchange
dieses dieser austausch
das geht natürlich ein herber zum
fenster wenn man sich aus um sich
austauschen zu können muss es eine
gewisse verbindung gegeben das heißt es
müsse ein weg vom einen zum anderen
geben zu müssen durchgang geben fenster
und dann kann da so eine art von
interaktion stattfinden also
kommunikation letztendlich es sei ja
auch ziemlich kommunikativ aus sah so
aus ich weiß nicht wie ich den eindruck
sie hatten
haben sie den eindruck nach diesem
kurzfilm dass coco eine sprache spricht
haben wir einfach mal eine abstimmung
wird dafür ist so einmal kurz die hand
heben mit der meinung ist dass eine
sprache gesprochen hat wer meint es
wurde keine sprache gesprochen so auch
mal hier die mehrheit ist der meinung
dass eine sprache gesprochen wird
tragbar doch einfach mal jetzt die
teilnehmer hier diejenigen von ihnen die
sich gemeldet haben und der meinung
waren dass es eine sprache ist was sind
die anzeichen was sind die gründe oder
was sind die beobachtungen die sie da
jetzt machen konnten die für sie
letztendlich indiz dafür sind dass es
sprache ist die coco aliens gesprochen
hat unabhängig davon dass der app der
sprecher die these vertreten hat das
dass die sprache sein man kann das ja
immer in frage stellen
gut also sie sagen sozusagen durch
dieses puppenspiel kann coco sich in
eine bestimmte rolle versetzen er kann
sich von sich selbst unterscheiden er
hat selbstbewusstsein vielleicht sogar
und das ist natürlich auch eine wichtige
bedingung für sprachen haben sie sonst
noch mögliche gründe oder indizien dafür
dass es sich um eine sprache handelt
sie haben noch ein punkt genannt diese
flexibilität der zeichen dass nicht nur
starre konditionierung sondern kann je
nach situation oder sie ist ja ein
weiblicher affe sie kann je nach
situation zeichen verwenden ganz spontan
auch flexibel kombinieren dies nicht
angewiesen auf eine bestimmte vorgabe
ok hat diese eindruck sonst noch jemand
von ihnen gehabt dass kuka bisschen
nachgeholfen hat da ist noch so ein
eindruck erweckt worden
also mir schien es jedenfalls auch so
jemanden ich sage jetzt schieben wir
müssen dann natürlich immer skeptisch
sein
wir schienen es auch so dass die sich
sehr gut verstanden haben
es waren einmal die skeptiker unter
ihnen hören wer ist der meinung nochmal
wer möchte mal was sagen dazu warum es
nicht nur sprache sein könnte oder
vielleicht auch nicht ist wer von ihnen
möchte meine gegenposition dazu eröffnen
ja bitte
naja gut sonst noch skeptische position
dagegen hier lesen sie nochmal komplexe
konditionierung man könnte sagen nur
bezogen auf diese person diese
forscherin die tierforscherin mit der
kommuniziert wurde
sie würden sagen es ist ein komplexes
spiel was nach bestimmten regeln abläuft
aber es wäre nicht so frei so flexibel
dass es wirklich den namen sprache
verdient eine komplexe konditionierung
so wie sie es sagen ja da war noch eine
meldung
also wir haben da nur ein ausschnitt
wir haben vier minuten die forscherin
weiß wie die bedeutung der zeichen ist
es ist was geschlossen ist ein
geschlossenes system eine sprache müsste
es gibt natürlich noch mehr
untersuchungen dazu eine sprache müsste
offen dass sein
wir müssen schauen ob coco auch mit
anderen personen korrespondieren
kommunizieren kann
nach einer weile und ob er eben nach
ganz ganz flexiblen situation in der
lage ist seine zeichen anzuwenden zu
kommunizieren in unvorhergesehenen
situationen wie jetzt nicht antrainiert
sind ja
das nächste sprache werden
wahrscheinlich die erste-aktie benutzen
um mit allen möglichen mitteln zu
kommunizieren also zum beispiel wenn er
jetzt mit
naja ich meine oder punkt es gibt ich
hab sie nicht vergessen ganzen es gibt
sicherlich auch verschiedene sprach
begriffe einen anspruchsvolleren sprach
begriff und einen rudimentären sprach
betrieb auf was auch so zeichensprache
anbelangt wir wenn wir von uns aus gehen
wir sind so verfasst dass wenn wir eine
sprache können dass wir versuchen mit
allem lebendigen was irgendwie sich
bewegt was vernünftig sein könnte zu
kommunizieren
wir versuchen immer kontakt aufzunehmen
das scheint auch in so einem komplexen
anspruchsvollen begriff der sprache
enthalten zu sein
diese dieser im petto ist diese
imperativ der kontaktaufnahme
sprachlicher art mit allem was der
lebendig ist und da wäre die frage ob
das bei coco der fall ist und ob er wenn
es nicht der fall ist ob man es dennoch
nicht vielleicht noch sprache nehmen
können das war ganz hinten im mir
ich glaube die ist schon ziemlich
ziemlich elaborierte gebärdensprache
das weiß nur von von taubstummen das
zornige gebärdensprache extrem
differenziert ist es wird natürlich
jetzt keine taubstumme sprache sein die
coco hier jetzt angewendet habe ich dann
wohl so mischform aber gebärdensprache
ist natürlich extrem komplex und man
sieht ja auch immer diese
simultandolmetscher in gebärdensprache
manchmal also das kann da kann das thema
noch so kompliziert sein
es wird immer umgesetzt in diese gebühr
in diese zeichensysteme das war hier
noch eine meldung ja
ja
guter punkt also da ist eine gewisse
abhängigkeit vielleicht gegeben und man
könnte das jetzt vielleicht so eine art
von privat sprache
ich schreibe es in anführungsstrichen
geht natürlich auch wittgenstein zurück
privat sprache ist bei wittgenstein nur
bezogen auf das individuum auf das
objekt aber es könnte so eine besonders
apart von privat sprache sein die
einfach nur zwischen zwei individuen
besteht die sich besonders gut verstehen
und dann wäre es wieder so ein komplexes
konditionierung system
es war da noch nicht
also ein guter punkt und das ist ein
argument was immer wieder gebracht wird
und was wir ernst nehmen müssen also man
könnte sagen wenn ich sie richtig
verstanden habe vielleicht erkennen wir
nur nicht dieses zeichen system von coco
was er eigentlich hat wir können es
nicht wissen ob er nicht doch eine
sprache hat wie was sagen sie zu diesem
argument ich formuliere noch mal ein
bisschen anders also vielleicht erkennen
wir nicht dieses zeichensystem vasco da
verwendet als sprach erkennen es nämlich
was ist dazu zu sagen nehmt das heißt so
so hat von natur aus hat genau das meint
also vielleicht erkennen wir nicht die
katzen sprache vielleicht erkennen wir
nur nicht die mäuse sprache ich mäuse
haben vielleicht so unscheinbare
zeichensysteme die uns einfach entgegen
was wäre auf so ein argument zu
antworten wenn man sagt tiere können
durchaus sprache haben wir erkennen es
nur nicht wieder nicht in diesem
denksystem drin ist drin sind ja ganze
ja mit unserer beschränktheit unsere
kognitiven beschränkte dieser
ameisenhaufen ist ein gutes beispiel
in diesem text den wir jetzt gleich nach
genauer lesen den ich herumgeschickt
hatte wird darauf bezogen haben auf
diesen ameisenhaufen da wird dann ein
urteil gefällt ob es sich bei ameisen um
eine sprache handeln der text den wir
jetzt gleich lesen argumentiert dagegen
sagt ameisen haben keine sprache gibt
also kriterien dafür was eine sprache
ist klar wir müssen erst mal definieren
was ein sprache ist aber von unserem
wagen vorgespurt verständnis dass
sprache eine komplexe art von
kommunikation ist die nicht nur
konditioniert ist das war sie man sagen
sie ist nicht nur konditioniert sind sie
flexibel und sie lässt sich in
verschiedenen situationen immer anwenden
und sie besteht auch nicht nur zwischen
zwei individuen sind prinzipiell ist sie
sich übertragen auf alle möglichen
individuum und kommunikationsform ich
glaube dass man das durchaus zu diesen
charakteristika von sprache zählen kann
müssen wir schauen ob ameisen oder
andere lebensformen nach diesen
merkmalen die sprache verfügen ich
wollte nur noch ein impuls geben
und noch ein bisschen betonen diese
systemische einschränkungen die wir
haben und die zweiseitig problematisch
ist das habe ich setzte mir auch schon
kurz gesagt
das ist eine ästhetische problem ist
oder methodologische problem ist wie wir
zu diesen fremd psychischen tier
überhaupt hinüber kommen da ist ja von
natur aus eine kluft wir sind psychisch
verfasst wir sind mental verfasst wie
gelangen wird zum anderen mental wie
können wir diese kluft schließen das
mentale kluft wie können wir dieses
fenster öffnen das ist also ein problem
anhand von welchen kriterien können wir
sprache feststellen dass sind also
hermeneutische probleme ein anderes
problem ist und deshalb wächst auch aus
unserer erkenntnistheoretischen
einschränkung wie können wir sicher sein
dass wenn ich fälschlicherweise dem tier
jetzt da eine sprache unterstellen
obwohl es sie gar nicht hat das sind
also das muss man immer diese zwei
seiten muss man immer berücksichtigen
einmal wie können wir überhaupt das tier
ernst nehmen in seiner psychischen
verfasst hat vielleicht auch in seiner
sprachkompetenz
wie können wir also hermeneutische
technologisch diese sprache erkennen wie
können die ihm gerecht werden wenn wir
im gerecht werden wollen bedeutet dass
wir müssen diese kluft schließen die
zwischen uns und dem tier steht ein
problem aber das andere was genau so
wichtig ist genauso schwierig schwer
wiegt ist wie können wir sicherstellen
dass wir uns nichts vormachen oder
nichts hineinprojizieren investieren wir
neigen dazu alles andere immer nach uns
zu bewerten das ist diese antwort
prozent riss oder andere pommer office
muss wir neigen dazu tieren gewisse
menschlichen verhaltensweisen zu
unterstellen
zu recht oder zu unrecht ist die frage
aber es ist einfach in unserer natur
gelegen anderes an uns zu messen und
dessen also zwei gefahren die wir
vermeiden müssen wenn wir wirklich eine
form von sprache oder von geist wie wir
es ja nicht beim tier identifizieren
also ist es tun sich ganz viele
ästhetische
probleme auf wenn es um die frage nach
der bestimmung des geistes der tiere
geht neben dem definitorischen sinn
neben dem definitorischen problem was in
der letzten sitzung auch schon kurz
angesprochen hatte dass man erst mal
erklären muss was überhaupt geist ist
und sie haben bestimmt alle diesen
artikel von mir gelesen auf die seminar
über dem deutschen begriff des geistes
wir meinen jetzt nicht im deutschen
mittel von geist in seiner
vieldeutigkeit wie begeistert 19
jahrhunderts der geist des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts der geisterstadt münchen
von sowas sprechen wir nicht wenn vom
geiste tiere sprechen wir man einfach
das mentale verschiedene mentale akte
die intensität sprache bewusst sein
selbstbewusstsein vielleicht freiheit
solche dinge sind mit geistigkeit
gemeint und mit diesem
problembewusstsein im hinterkopf wollen
wir uns jetzt diesem text nochmal
genauer zu wenden denen ich ihn herum
geschickt hatte also aus diesem
sammelband der geist der tiere
philosophische texte zu einer aktuellen
diskussion ist auch schon über zehn
jahre her
dieses thema geist der tiere hat immer
mal wieder ein aufschwung oder wieder
ein abschwung das bisschen zyklisch
gerade ist es nicht mehr so im trend
aber vor zehn jahren ungefähr war es
bisschen mehr im bewusstsein dennoch ist
ein wichtiges thema weil wir damit nicht
nur über uns selbst sprechen als
menschen als selbstlos gewesen sondern
über was anderes was auch lebendig ist
und auch und geist haben könnte und
deshalb natürlich auch sehr viel über
uns selbst aus dem umkehrschluss dass
wir nicht nur über den menschen an toko
zentristische oder mit peter singer
gesprochen spezies ist ich schreibe
diesen begriff auch noch hin
speziesismus speziesismus ist von peter
sehr geprägt worden
peter singer ist ein tierschützer ein
intellektueller tierschützer
der buch geschrieben hat mit dem titel
animal liberation die befreiung der
tiere den 70ern als auch schon eine
weile her
peter singer sagt speziesismus ist die
position dass wir menschen nur aufgrund
unserer spezies ein wert genießen und
die tiere nicht weil sie nicht uns was
pcs angehören und speziesismus ist in
analogie zum rassismus begriff geprägt
worden
also dass es auf die rasse oder auf die
spezies ankäme um einen wert zu haben
und peter singer hat dieses speziesismus
problem auch sehr stark mit moralischen
fragestellung in verbindung gebracht
also die frage ob tiere über geist
verfügen ist nicht nur ein theoretisches
thema nicht nur von theoretischen
interesse sondern auch von praktischen
weil wenn sich jetzt herausstellen
sollte dass tiere über geist sowie in
wien jetzt im engeren sinne bestimmt
haben verfügen dann gewisse phänomene
für sie eine ganz andere bedeutung
hätten als wir gemeinhin annehmen
stellte mir vor ein tier hätte sprachen
ein tier hätte ein begriff vom tod wenn
sie man sich mal diesen
wikipedia-artikel über coco durchlesen
habe ich jetzt vorhin kurz gemacht
empfinden sie dort die information dass
coco angeblich sogar eine vorstellung
vom tod hatte also diese forscherin die
wir gerade gesehen hatten die fragte
coco loco was passiert nach dem leben
nach dem ende des lebens und dann muss
coco wohl so drei begriffe genannt haben
irgendwie auf wiedersehen höhle und
angenehm und irgendwie sowas höhle
also natürlich ist das jetzt hoch
spekulativ meint jetzt gut dass man da
in eine höhle kommt in ein rad
totenreich und dass es schön dort ist
kann man sich jetzt überlegen
wenn das der fall wäre dass tiere über
einen begriff des lebens und des todes
verfügen
dann hätten sie natürlich auch ein sehr
großes leidens potenzial was zum
beispiel jetzt die gefangenschaft
anbetrifft was ja todesangst anbetrifft
und dann hätte man auch eine moralische
verpflichtung tieren ganz anders
entgegen zu kommen als wir es bisher tun
da werden sie sollen uns eben würde die
methode des tages und so weiter und so
fort und sie hätten ein ganz anderes
schmerzempfinden oder leid empfinden
angesichts bestimmte konstellationen und
das würde dann durchaus moralisch
bedeuten dass wir mit ihnen anders
umgehen müssen als wir es bis jetzt also
ich wollte nur sagen es gibt hier immer
auch noch neben diesen ganzen
theoretischen fragestellungen praktische
fragestellungen die aber im wesentlichen
von der klärung der theoretischen
fragestellung abhängen nur wenn tiere
wirklich ein geist haben haben wir unter
umständen gute gründe ihn ein wert
zuzusprechen unabhängig natürlich als
ein lebenswertes unabhängig natürlich
von der frage ob mich das leben
grundsätzlich als solches geschützt
werden muss sie kennen alle diese
theorien die sagen wir ihm gefolgt von
albert schweitzer die ehrfurcht vor dem
leben das gibt es natürlich auch
das problem ist nur der lebensmittel
bisher weit auch tiere und pflanzen
leben auch kleinere lebewesen oder
lebewesen die keine besonders
entwickelte denn gehirne haben leben und
dann stellt sich die frage ja wo fangen
wir an das leben grundsätzen zu schützen
lässt sich das überhaupt realisieren wir
sehen wir kommen wieder zurück auf die
frage nach dem geiste tiere eine der
wert des tieres die schützenswerte
status hängt wohl auch sehr eng mit der
theoretischen frage zusammen auch wenn
in diesem seminar nur die theoretischen
also vorwiegend die theoretischen fragen
nach den merkmalen nach der technologie
der geistigen merkmale im zentrum stehen
jetzt würde ich sagen lesen einfach mal
ein bisschen aus diesem text und schauen
auch wieder mit einfach stellen
sind diese texte jetzt lesen ist eine
sehr gute einführung ich muss gestehen
meine einfach in der letzten sitzung war
relativ unabhängig von diesem text und
sie stimmen eigentlich ziemlich gut
überein
und dass ich noch so präsent hatte aber
vielleicht sind sie auch anderer meinung
er vertritt jedenfalls klare thesen zum
leben und zur schätzung zur sprache zum
sprachvermögen bestimmte tieren
problematisiert hast wollen wir
vielleicht einfach mal drei nachlesen
wollen sie vielleicht mal beginnt
einfach her
diesen ersten textabschnitte
blankenheim leisten ist ihnen erlauben
würde im wörtlichen sinne etwas zu
verleihen oder zu wollen sie sind
analysen deren verhalten durch eine
genetische anlage hinter klein bis dahin
also sie haben einen wichtigen begriff
gebracht nämlich diese anthropomorphe
zieren die redeweise wer von ihnen kann
noch mal sagen was eine anthropomorphen
zieren die redeweise ist er möchte das
noch mal sage ich schreibe es auch
nochmal hin anthroposophisch muss
anthroposophisch muss ja bitte
genau und das muss wie sie richtig sagen
jetzt nicht nur mit tieren stattfinden
sind es kann mit allem lebendigen
stattfinden mit pflanzen wie dort in
diesem text gesagt es kann sogar so weit
gehen dass man es in dinge hinein
projiziert
also der stein schweiz der stein war
stumm
sie kennen das vielleicht in goethes
werther die leiden des jungen werther
der wird die gesamte natur zur
projektionsfläche der subjektivität
dieser empfindsamen wirklichkeit also
strom und tragen empfindsamkeit haben
einen so gesteigerten antrag vom office
muss dass die gesamte natur zum
spiegelbild der inneren zustände wird da
ist also drückt sie drückt die natur als
ganze gesamte meine jetzige stimmung aus
und sie kennen es sicherlich auch von
sich wenn sie in einer bestimmten
stimmung sind dann nehmen sie natürlich
auch die natur oder dass die außenwelt
an das war und sie sind auch unter
umständen geneigt nicht nur dass ihren
zustand zuzusprechen zuzuschreiben
sondern eben der außenwelt also dieser
schluss dass man eben das ganze dann
nicht nur in sich sieht sondern auch in
die welt überträgt der ist recht häufig
und der gehört zum antrieb um office
muss wir müssen eben aufpassen dass wir
diesen anthropologisch muss vermeiden
das problem ist wir kommen nicht aus
unserer haut heraus wir sind nunmal
unhintergehbare menschen wir haben große
probleme uns auf den standpunkt zu
versetzen in einen standpunkt zu
versetzen der nicht menschlich ist das
geht nicht bekommen nicht aus selbst
wenn wir uns auf so einen standpunkt
versetzen in einen solchen standpunkt
versetzen ist es immer noch der mensch
der sich in einen solchen standpunkt
versetzt es ist also das in einen
standpunkt versetzen des menschen wir
kommen da nicht raus selbst wenn wir uns
irgendwie da ein konstrukt machen was
nicht mehr menschlich sei was eben der
neutrale beobachter ist der neutrale
stand
ist es halt der neutralen standpunkt des
menschen
wir kommen nicht raus das ist so eine
wiesn thematik die wir immer
berücksichtigen müssen
und das bringt mich nur zum weiteren
punkt den ich in meiner zusammenfassung
die ich herumgeschickt habe und die
hoffentlich verständlich war war sie
verständlich oder war sie braucht man
also diese zusammenfassung da habe ich
auch geschrieben dass wir bei diesem
thema jetzt geist der tiere angewiesen
sind auf daten oder informationen
experimente von anderen wissenschaften
die produzieren wir selbst nicht wir
können begriffliche klärungen
durchführen als philosophin und
philosophen ihr könnt sagen was es heißt
das macht den naturwissenschaften nicht
die kann nicht sagen was geist ist ich
kann sagen was gehirn ist das geistes
kann sie nicht kompetent sagen wir
können als philosophen die merkmale die
akte unterscheiden die geistig genannt
werden können
bei diesem thema geiste tiere sind wir
angewiesen auf daten der
naturwissenschaften der tierforschung
verhaltensforschung psychologie aber wie
ich schrieb die daten sprechen nie für
sich jede datengrundlage bedarf einer
interpretation immer die frage wie wir
es deuten
und da kommen wir philosophen daneben
wir haben die daten
wir haben gewisse experimente wie jetzt
diesen film und wir versuchen diesen
film zu verstehen wir versuchen ihn zu
begreifen zu ordnen zu klassifizieren
nach bestimmten kategorien die wir da
vorher säuberlich differenziert haben
das wäre die position der philosophie
trotz ihrer angewiesen haid auf
naturwissenschaftliche kenntnisse sobald
es um die interpretation geht und
interpretation ist alles letztendlich
die daten sprechen wie gesagt nur sehr
sehr selten für sich sind wir durchaus
auch im bereich der geisteswissenschaft
und im speziellen der philosophie ja das
ist also eine gewisse vorsichtsmaßnahmen
die ziel gebracht wird dann lesen wir
vielleicht mal
heute wählt der nächste kommt ohne
einfach lesen erst diese tatsache
zugrunde dass menschen ein bewusstsein
haben daran dass externe besonders in
der deckung gespielt und uns selber
unseren mitmenschen ein geist zu
schneiden
wir haben nämlich ein schönes erlebnis
wenn wir etwas waren oder erfüllte sie
für uns in dieser spielklasse noch nicht
im handel ist phänomenal poster
empfiehlt ihr selbst dann dass mit mir
nicht in der lage sind genauso probieren
sie das thema nicht
dank bis dahin weiß jemand von ihnen
noch wie man diese phänomene nennt in
der fachsprache lag war ja ich schreibe
es auch nochmal hin also qualia ist ein
plural begriff da ist jemand wieder
singular von quali heißt ja ein quale
von lateinisch qualys und quali ist es
neutrum also das wie es ist in einem
bestimmten zustand zu sein
das wie sei das ist ein quark wahljahr
sind dann in ein psychisches ist seins
phänomene könnte man sagen und an den
zeigt sich ganz besonders dass wir
schwierigkeiten haben solche phänomene
von anderen bewusstsein zu verstehen
nachzuvollziehen zu empfinden
da haben wir eine trennung eine
kategorische trennung des fremd
psychischen wir können höchstens solche
qualia erschließen zb schmerz schmerz
reaktionen sind häufig ähnlich das sehen
sie dann bei der haut die haut die die
light barkeit der haut wenn man schmerz
empfindet zeigt sich dieses phänomen
zeichenhaft in verschiedenen anderen
körperlichen reaktionen so dass ich
darauf zurück schließen können dass da
jetzt schmerz vorliegt bei einem
bestimmten tier aber wie sich genau
dieser schmerz anfühlt können sie mit
der bloßen zeichenhaften struktur die
auf das vorhandensein von schmerz
verweist natürlich nicht gehen
das ist klar genau genommen
das ist das allgemeine problem des fremd
psychischen nur können wir eben als
menschen uns darüber verständigen
man muss sich jetzt fragen ob das tiere
vielleicht auch können wir können sagen
dieser schmerz war sowie und das
versuchen zu beschreiben
aber genau genommen können wir dem das
fremd psychische eines anderen menschen
auch nie so nachvollziehen
insofern ist es so diese diese diese
sache mit thomas nagel wie es ist eine
fledermaus zu sein gilt natürlich in
einer abgeschwächten form auch für uns
menschen
ich weiß nicht wie es ist einer von
ihnen zu sein wie sie nicht wissen wie
es ist wichtig zu sein im phänomenalen
empfinden nur können wir uns darüber
eben austauschen und versuchen die sache
zu veranschaulichen durch die sprache
jetzt hatten sie sich doch gemeldet
genau das problem ist eben nur dass man
kann immer sagen wir können sie ja noch
nicht wissen
also ist die dieser punkt der
kommilitonen von vorhin natürlich könnte
es irgendwie sein dass wir es nur noch
nicht heraus bekommen haben
aber dann ist es immer die frage nach
dem standpunkt der beweislast
also es ist es eine art juristisches
juristisches juristische position
mir scheint aber darüber können wir
diskutieren wenn wir das jetzt
meteorologisch betrachtet mir scheint es
tatsächlich so sein dass das andere das
tier nicht dadurch schon irgendwie
bewusstsein zugeschrieben bekommen kann
weil wir es nicht wissen könnten sind
mir scheint der andere weg sind voller
zu sein
wir müssen alles versuchen um es heraus
zu bekommen
wir können natürlich nicht alles machen
es geht nicht wir haben selbst auch
grenzen wir sollten alles versuchen
kriterien entwickeln anhand deren sich
zeigt dass da irgendwas geistiges
bis diese kriterien sollten wir
möglichst abstrakt entwickeln und das
machen wir auch jetzt im folgenden
semesters und da sehr differenziert
vorgehen und alle gefahren das
anthropozän tourismus eindruck vom
office muss ausschließen auch wenn es
sehr schwierig ist und dann mit diesen
kategorien an die konkreten phänomene
herantreten und dann schauen ob sich
bestätigt und wenn nicht bin ich der
meinung darüber kann man diskutieren
sind wir berechtigt davon auszugehen
dass geist vorliegt oder nicht das ist
also die frage nach der argumentation
last oder der beweispflicht
also ich glaube eben wir können bei
tieren wie jetzt bei coco sehr sehr
interessante dinge beobachten die den
schluss nahelegen dass es hier sich um
eine sprache handelt weil ihr sehr
flexible flexibler zeichen gebrauch
stattfindet weil sich coco glaube ich
als einziges tier im spiegel als solches
bewusst erkennt und selbstbewusstsein
rudimentäres selbstbewusstsein hat das
steht auch in diesem wikipedia artikeln
das sind ergebnisse von objektiven tests
die uns etwas nahe liegen und das können
wir eben bei pflanzen so nicht sehen
auch wenn natürlich pflanzen theoretisch
selbst sein haben könnte natürlich
es wäre möglich aber wir haben keine
anhaltspunkte dass ist das problem
und da kommt dann immer diese frage nach
dem beweis pflicht ins spiel und ich
glaube wenn wir sehr wohlwollend sind
wenn wir solche die versuchen
auszuschließen hineinprojizieren aber
auch diese diese spezies tische moment
jetzt welche moralischen sinne sind
diese anthropozän touristische dass wir
nur uns bezogen sind wir versuchen das
auszuschließen nach bestem wissen und
gewissen dann glaube ich sind wir in
einer guten position kategorien
anzuwenden ein test zu machen nach
bestimmten vorliegenden kriterien die
die ergebnisse zu untersuchen und dann
zu entscheiden ist es nahe liegend oder
nicht wir können immer sagen ja der
stein könnte auch selbstbewusstsein
haben ich kann s t mission erweisen
wir sollten also immer die frage ob
selbstbewusstsein vorliegt oder
so scheint mir ist anhand einem gewissen
kriterien festmachen gibt es
anhaltspunkte die wir objektivieren
können
und das können wir im falle von sprache
schon das muss interaktion auf hohe
flexibilität grad erfolgen
es muss vielleicht eine struktur von
selbstbewusstsein vorhanden sein es muss
flexibilität vorhanden seien und dass
sie innerhalb lang steinig natürlich
könnt ihr trotzdem zum bewusstsein haben
klagen aber dann ist es eben mystik weil
dann könnten wir dann kommen wir nie zu
einem punkt objektiv irgendwas zu
entwickeln da kann man noch drauf wir
kommen jetzt gleich in diesem zitat was
wir jetzt lesen da kommen wir jetzt
drauf auf licht empfindungen solche
sachen und ich will damit nicht sagen
dass dieser text in jetzt lesen
allgemeinverbindlich ist ich bin sehr
dafür dass wir immer in der diskussion
treten
aber dann müssen wir versuchen dass
anhand von kriterien festzumachen
welche kriterien könnte es denn dann
geben die wir nicht erkennen können
vielleicht über die oder welche
eigenschaft müssen vorliegen die wir
vielleicht nicht erkennen können die
eben jetzt der stein haben müsste wir
müssen die aussehen welche gründe
sprechen dafür solche eigenschaften die
wir nicht erkennen können anzunehmen
so müssten wir dann halt eben weiter
analysieren es war ganz hinten meldung
hier
ja genau da gibt es eben dieses
potential itc argument über das man sich
streiten kann potenzial i tät meint es
ist angelegt der möglichkeit nach in
diesem kind nennen auch wenn es
natürlich als neugeborenes faktisch auf
dem stand eines jeden anderes säugetier
ist oder im embryonalen zustand meines
wissens vielleicht entdeckt man mit der
zeit noch das selbst im embryonalen
zustand dort bereits gewisse eigenschaft
vorliegen die es vom anderen embryonalen
zuständen andere säugetier unterscheiden
aber so prima vater ist ein neugeborenes
vergleich ermitteln jedem anfang soll
geht prima aber es hat eben in sich
diese potenz diese entwicklung hin zu
einem selbstbewussten wesen und die
hirnstruktur die ganze genetik ist
darauf ausgelegt mal sprache zu
entwickeln
im normalfall vorausgesetzt auch gewisse
andere umgebungen sind der fall und das
ist eben bei anderen säugetieren unter
umständen nicht der fall
das ist eben nicht genetisch angelegt
ist das nicht so ein komplexes
nervensystem ja codiert ist genetisch
also könnte man über die gibt das
potenzial itc argument com
ich will damit nicht sagen dass dieses
potenzial itc argument nicht auch
problematisch ist auch sehr
problematisch da gibt es eine riesen
diskussion darum und den status von
potenzen die wir annehmen aber
normalerweise entwickelt sich halt ein
kind aufgrund seiner dna menschlichen
dna zu einem sprach fähigen wesen weil
auch das gehirn sich normalerweise so
entwickelt dass es besonders komplex ist
dass es einen sehr ausgeprägten
präfrontalen kortex hat dass die
hirnrinde sehr differenziert ist alle
die evolution der jüngsten zahlen stufen
des gehirns sehr ausgeprägt sind an
denen ja diese meisten kognitiven
kapazitäten also an organisch gelagert
sind dass es eben bei andere säugetier
nicht der fall
was nicht heißt dass sie vielleicht
nicht auch sprache haben
das ist offen das muss nicht mit einem
besonders entwickelten präfrontalen
kortex notwendigerweise einhergehen oder
besonderen hirnstrukturen könnte auch in
tiefer liegenden schichten der fall sein
müssen wir natürlich dann immer die
hirnforscher fragen aber jetzt würde ich
sagen lesen wir mal das nächste zitat
weil wir dann auf ihren punkt kommen mit
diesen pflanzen gehabt wenn sie mal
lesen
[Musik]
einfach wasser bis dahin ja dieses zitat
hatten wir das schon gelesen dass hier
geld das hatten wir gelesen genau ist
richtig ja wie sehen sie das stimmen sie
dem zu also die these was ist die these
in diesem zitat also welche argumente
sind jetzt in diesem zitat enthalten die
die autoren vorbringen um pflanzen
nichts geistiges zuzuschreiben oder
umpflanzen geistige merkmale
abzusprechen
richtig und sie wollen es vielleicht
auch nicht sie haben vielleicht keinen
willen oder war das eine meldung bei ok
sonst nur punkte also dass man sagt das
was ich jetzt er strebe er strebe ich
als ein objekt und da ist eine tendenz
sie sehen jetzt schon das erste problem
hier haben wir jetzt die rede von wollen
von wünschen
das sind natürlich motto des welt
bezuges die besonders von der gefahr des
anthropozän tourismus betroffen sind
also neben gefühlen und sonstigen dingen
ist von den ersten geneigt fremden wesen
oder sonstigen strukturen so was wie in
will zuzuschreiben
das ist also der klassische antrup home
office muss der willens anthroposophisch
muss das kommt in meinen augen darüber
kann man sich auch sicherlich streiten
gleich nach den gefühlen in der meinung
wird der antrieb home office muss ist
zunächst mal einer der gefühle irgendwo
glaubt festmachen zu können gefühle
vielleicht auch auf derselben ebene und
dann kommt aber sehr bald auch dieser
antrieb office muss das des willens des
des wollens ist absicht iges vielleicht
ist sogar noch vor dem gefühl was nicht
heißt dass es dort nicht irgendwelche
geistige strukturen geben könnte
ja wir stehen sie jetzt dazu überzeugt
sie das haben pflanzen intention ali-t
sind pflanzen gerichtet im sinne von
wünschen
sagen nicht warum nicht was ist der
grund
reiz reaktions schemata wenn zu wenig
wasser ist dann wird das ausgelöst dann
wird dieser prozess getriggert sozusagen
automatisch schon fast davor war noch
eine meldung hier nicht sonst ganz hier
richtig also jetzt was die determination
anbelangt sicherlich aber die
hirnforscher würden auch wenn sie noch
so starke deterministischen sind
sicherlich so was wie intentional i tät
zugestehen intensität also mir scheint
dass intensität nicht wegfällt wenn wir
vollständige terminiert sind
auch wenn internationalität häufig auch
mit freiheit in verbindung gebracht wird
aber es scheint dass ein phänomen
eigener komplexität zu sein dass auch
angesichts einer vollständigen
determination denkt möglich ist genau
aber es ist gut aber es ist immerhin ein
bewusstsein von intensität was bei
pflanzen nicht vorhanden sein muss oder
vorhanden wäre dann nach diesem modell
das wäre schon mal ein phänomenaler
unterschieden ist die frage nach der
freiheit ist mal dahin gestellt
ich meine ich wenn die pflanze hat
sicherlich in sich ein drang oder so war
es ein lebensdrang oder eine richtung
zur sonne zum licht aber ob man das eben
internationalität nennen sollte
intensität im sinne dieses geistigen akt
ist es scheint doch eher sowas wie sie
einfach so eine sehr natürliche
elaborierter reaktions reizt es sein
sich eben am licht auszurichten und
dorthin zu wachsen
ich meine ich kann sie verstehen ihr
argument wäre offensichtlich dass das
ich sagen nach diesem reiz reaktions
gleich schema zu urteilen wäre zu
mechanisch gedacht sie sagen also eine
pflanze ist doch keine maschinen
und ich glaube das ist ein wichtiger
punkt wir müssen immer bedenken dass wir
von pflanzen auch wenn sie jetzt
vielleicht nicht internationale systeme
sind immer noch die maschinen abgrenzen
müssen weil maschinen keine lebewesen
pflanzen sind lebe wirst sind organismen
die sind geschlossen in sich und haben
dadurch eine qualität die sie von großem
reiz reaktions maschinen unterscheidet
bereits reaktions maschinen nicht dieses
selbst erhalten geschlossene system
besitzen aber eben ob daraus folgt dass
es die meinen man könnte sagen reiz
reaktions schema muss man unterscheiden
zwei typen
es gibt ein reiz reaktions schema was
nur bei maschinen vorliegt komplexen
maschinen und ein reiz reaktions
schimmer was bei lebewesen oder
organismen vorliegt hätte man sagen ihre
intuition eingefangen ohne damit sagen
zu müssen dass da jetzt internationale
zustände vor vorhanden sind aber ich
glaube sie haben zu recht darauf
hingewiesen dass wir das noch von losen
maschine abgrenzen müssen nur sind
maschinen leben nicht sind keine
organismen auch wenn ein auto so komplex
ist dass man geneigt ist steuert sich
selbst es registriert selbst wann das
benzin aufhört aber ein auto könnte
sogar mal irgendwann so
weit gediehen sein dass es dann selbst
irgendwie sich nährstoffe sage jetzt mal
zu führt oder so
aber da ist noch ein weiter weg hin dass
sich auch selbst austauschen
das ist also wenn seine reifen selbst
wechselt dass es seine fehlenden teile
selbst produziert generiert das ist ja
bei lebewesen der fall bei pflanzen also
sie haben sehr recht darauf hinzuweisen
dass selbst wenn wir jetzt mechanistisch
sprechen davon zwei fälle unterscheiden
müssen jetzt habe erst hier eine meldung
bei ihren
es ist nicht das motiv zu sagen
guter punkt also sie bringen jetzt das
argument der ontologischen sparsamkeit
ins spiel ich weiß nicht das haben sie
sicherlich schon mal gehört und logische
sparsamkeit heißt wir sollten in
theorien nur dasjenige postulieren oder
annehmen was unbedingt notwendig ist um
gewisse phänomene zu erklären und alles
was nicht irgendwie notwendig ist
sollten wir außen vor lassen und wir
sollten sogar so davon denken als ob es
nicht geben auch wenn wir das nicht 100
prozent natürlich beweisen können wir
sollten aus methodischen gründen es
streichen und unsere und weil es einfach
ballast ist unnötiger ballast wir
sollten unsere beschreibung unsere
theorien der wirklichkeit so schlank wie
möglich halt mit vornamen oder
ökologischen prämissen und das wäre dann
ebenso ein punkt das war sehr gut wir
können jetzt pflanzen nach so einem
komplexen organischen reiz reaktions
schimmer schreiben und dann brauchen wir
nicht noch so etwas wie eine sonderform
von bewusstsein oder sonstige
internationalität annehmen je weniger
wir annehmen desto besser ist es
müssen wir beim menschen aber natürlich
auch gute gründe haben warum wir beim
menschen das dann annehmen oder bei
manchen tieren warum wir da nicht umhin
kommt ist es so ihr punkt gewesen ja ja
dazu noch was hier bitte
ja also ein guter punkt dass jetzt alles
offene fragen die wir jetzt mal im
hinterkopf behalten es gibt sicherlich
auch radikale der terminlisten radikale
naturalisten die so weit gehen würden
wir müssen dann eben immer schauen ob
wir den phänomenen noch gerecht werden
wir haben eine phänomenale basis
menschlicher lebensform pflanzlicher
lebensformen wir müssen schauen ob
unsere begriffe die wir haben unsere
systeme diesem phänomen gerecht werden
können wir alle mentalen prozesse so
beschreiben dass das können wir sie ins
national beschreiben
und da geht es erst mal
genau also wir könnten total
determiniert seien nicht willens frei
sein dennoch um internationale
internationale akte vollziehen
das wären einfach höhere komplexität
stufen von gegenstands bezug denen es
vielleicht sogar nicht weil pflanzen
gibt weil da gar kein gegenstand als
gegenstand bewusst ist oder erscheint
sondern weil irgendwelche auslöser
reagieren auf gewisse mangelzustände und
dann kompensations zustände folgen
das müssen wir mal offen lassen also den
fall der text hat eine konkrete these
die wir immer auch hier diskutieren
wollen dann lesen wir mal weiter wollen
sie gerade lesen
drittens der wald war das beziehung mit
einem bestimmten kontext zu bestimmten
zeiten verwendet werden
wenn wir sagen hier stand alles nicht
jene apps ist auch dadurch unterscheiden
uns im kreise von dem prinzen keine
fertigen aussagen äußern und mickys
kategorisieren können sie sind nicht in
der lage das beide klassen zu bilden und
auf ähnliche fälle anzuwenden der sich
immer noch viel weniger zustande dienst
tätig davon prädikaten etwa von dummheit
sind natürlich werden sie auch mit
anderen gefallen dass es nicht
vielen dank als sehen schon dieser text
argumentiert sehr stark in eine
bestimmte richtung und man könnte
durchaus zu recht jetzt an den text
diese frage stehen ja das ist doch als
er selbstsicher
könnte es nicht auch anders sein also
mann vermisst vielleicht in diesem text
etwas mehr begründung für diese sehr
starke these aber ich meine wir müssen
eben immer schauen was sind die
phänomene die sich uns bieten und allein
weil es möglich ist dass eine pflanze
jetzt geistige achse vollziehen könnte
nur weil wir nicht erkennen können
vielleicht das wäre eben nach diesem
prinzip der unter logische sparsamkeit
nicht aus aber es ist eben schon ist er
ja entschiedene these hier die bisschen
wenig begründet ist
da gebe ich ihnen recht all dem von
ihnen jetzt sagen dass geht mir jetzt
ein bisschen zu schnell
also hier fehlen noch so ein paar
zusatzprämien eine zusatzprämie wäre wie
der kommilitone gesagt hat und logische
spaß und kalt das ist ein generelles
prinzip von aller theoriebildung dass
wir möglichst wenige annahmen treffen
sollten dass wir eine theorie schlank
halten sollten
und je schlanker die theorie desto
besser ist er regiert
artikulation apparat der wäre halt hier
die frage ist das jetzt sprache oder ist
das eine rudimentäre form von
kommunikation oder wahnsystem die frage
die frage wer jetzt die hat der baum ein
phänomenales bewusstsein dieser gefahr
also ist sich der baum der gefahr
bewusst das ist die eine frage dass wir
dann quali oder ist es nicht nur so ein
auslöser reiz reaktions schema wenn hier
besonderes wasser fehlt wenn eine solche
situation gegeben ist die sich zum
beispiel in form eines waldbrands zeigt
dann wird das ausgelöst dann folgt das
weil es evolutionär dafür gesorgt hat
dass die meisten bäume überleben zu
einer situation und da können wir doch
immer noch sagen es ist das was jetzt
gerade gesagt habe deshalb ein ganz wo
die mend ihres bereits reaktions schema
weil dann haben wir die ontologische
sparsamkeit bewahrt und wir können diese
phänomene genauso gut erklären als wenn
wir annehmen dass er über phänomenales
bewusstsein verfügt
die frage ist immer können wir eine noch
schlankere beschreibung des selben
phänomens liefern
die ist eben genau so gut erklärt als
wenn wir noch zusätzlich anderen machen
die uns das phänomen aber nicht
unbedingt besser erklären das ist immer
die frage
richtig völlig richtig aber sie sagen ja
etwas außen vor zu lassen darin beziehen
sie sich auf bestimmte phänomene die wir
da nicht genug berücksichtigt haben das
heißt man müsste dann auf phänomene
hinweisen im falle von einer so einen
solchen baum die sich nicht mit einem
solchen schlanken reiz reaktions
schimmer fassen lassen dann müsste man
eben wieder die phänomene nehmen die
einem entgehen könnten
richtig aber dann würde man eben sagen
im zweifel nach unserer theorie jetzt so
wir können ja nicht wissen was noch
kommt wir müssen dann immer sagen wir
sind prinzipiell offen und skizzieren zu
lassen wie er jede naturwissenschaft
sich falls sie verzieren lassen können
muss sonst ist sie keine
naturwissenschaft es könnte immer
bessere neuere ergebnisse kommen aber
nach dem jetzigen wissensstand nach
unseren jetzigen theorien die wir nach
diesem prinzip hier bilden müssen wir
davon ausgehen dass es nicht vorliegt
phänomenales bewusstsein also dass es
nicht notwendig ist um dieses jahr zu
erklären ganz hinten und dann sehen
wenn sie haben wichtigen begriff genannt
zweck und ziel die frage ist eben ob
pflanzen über c kernziele verfügen dann
müsste man sie jetzt genauere gedanken
über den zweck begriff machen also
häufig ist das des tellers die theologie
man nach aristoteles ich meine es gibt
durchaus zwecke sage ich jetzt mal den
rudimentären sinn
die sind jetzt nicht bewusst aber
natürlich sagen in anführungsstrichen
haben evolutionär bedingt alle
lebensformen ein interesse zu überleben
im weitesten sinne nein das ist die
evolution die bewahrung der existenz
liebe
na ja gut ich meine es gibt gewisse
entwicklungen innerhalb der ohne dass
ich jetzt hier naturwissenschaftler bin
es gibt anpassungsprozesse nur
anpassungsprozesse die sich entwickeln
um veränderten äußeren umständen gerecht
zu werden besser angemessen zu sein
anpassungsprozesse man könnte jetzt
diesen anpassungsdruck und diese
anpassungsprozesse könnte man jetzt mit
einem sehr rudimentären zweck begriff
identifizieren dann wäre das kein
problem aber das wäre eben kein
anpassungsprozess der jetzt bewusst
vorliegt sonst wäre vielleicht dem sinne
verteilen terror sowas trial and error
wir versuchen mal es gibt verschiedene
mutationen und die mutation die eben am
besten überlegt die ist jetzt sich eben
fort das ist aber eine andere form von
zwick von ziel den wir bei bewussten
geistigen lebewesen vorfinden das ist ja
nicht nur trial and error es hat was
davon auch aber es ist doch noch
wesentlich reflektiert sie wirke moment
erst hatten sie sich gemeldet
ja ja aber
richtig ist hängt eben wieder am sprach
begriff wie man ihn definiert aber wir
haben jetzt ja schon so ein paar
kriterien bekommen wir lesen auch gleich
weiter aber hier gilt wieder das selbe
wie das was wir vorhergesagt hatten wir
sollten meteorologisch glaube ich erst
mal nicht zur starke begriffe anwenden
oder unterstellen wir können sagen die
rudimentäre kommunikation die wir nicht
sprache nennen genügt um dieses phänomen
zu beschreiben angemessen zu beschreiben
warnsignale botenstoffe botenstoffe sie
kennen alle botenstoffe im gehirn die
würden wir nicht als sprachliche
phänomene deuten sind einfach als
informationsverarbeitung wir können das
als informationsverarbeitung darstellen
ohne dass mit dass jede
informationsverarbeitung sprache ist
eine sprache sind besonders komplexe
qualitativ verschiedene formen von
informationsverarbeitung aber nicht jede
informationsverarbeitung ist sprachen
deswegen habe ich immer vom sprach
begriff ab aber wir haben jetzt jedoch
ein recht engen sprach begriffen sehr
anspruchsvollen sprach begriff den wir
hier in diesen phänomenen nicht an dem
müssen zwingend logisch
ich muss jetzt einfach mal weitergehen
wir haben nicht mehr so viel zeit weil
jetzt kommt noch die weiteren 14
schließlich das heißt es das letzte
charakteristikum des geistes nach
unseren autoren wir wollen das auch noch
mal kurz diskutieren ob die vier
merkmale ausreichend bitte
menschen ausbilden feststellen korrekt
ausgeführt weil so logischem denken im
stande sind
so können wir etwas sagen vielen dank
also nach dieser these der autoren wäre
so pflanzen vollziehen nie den modus
polens oder den modus collins oder was
auch immer bewusst sondern sie werden
vollzogen pflanzen sind nicht subjekt
der logik ist ein objekt einer
bestimmten logik der logik der anpassung
der logik der evolution oder was auch
immer
und jetzt genau zu bestimmen was
evolution ist die logik der umstände
sie haben bestimmt eine logik ich meine
pflanzen sind auf eine gewisse form
angepasst pflanzen haben eine
überlebensstrategie sozusagen aber es
ist nicht eine strategie die jetzt in
jedem pflanzlichen individuum als solche
bewusst reflektiert oder vollzogen wird
sondern man könnte und das ist ein
häufiges argument über das wir natürlich
auch noch treffen trefflich streiten
können pflanzen vielleicht auch tiere
vollziehen sich nicht als individuen
deal existieren nicht als individuen
sondern als mitglieder oder instanzen
einer gewissen art einer gewissen kultur
einer natürlichen kulturen in denen als
in den spielt das einst individuum keine
besonders große rolle
thema ameisenhaufen auf dem jetzt auch
gleich noch zu sprechen kommen ja es ist
die frage natürlich mein zu zu mutmaßen
ob jetzt da eine pflanzen logische
schluss gezogen hat das ist musik
aber es finden natürlich gewisse
prozesse statt die im gesamtkontext
gerechtfertigt sind die erscheinen als
gerechtfertigt was wie pflanzen
reagieren auf bestimmte situation dass
es sinnvollen das ist angemessen das ist
nicht sagen jetzt mal abträglich der
entwickler aber davon müssen
unterscheiden ob jetzt die einzelne
pflanze jetzt da eine entscheidung
gefällt hat oder ein logischer schluss
gezogen hat es ist wohl eher so dass die
gesamte art oder gattung wollte das
system hier funktionieren und nicht des
1 also ich möchte hier noch auf einen
punkt hinweisen der zu kurz kam bei
diesen vier merkmalen des geistes es ist
das thema individualität durchaus auch
individualität wie wir sie heute
allgemein verstehen also dass wir uns
als individuen zeichenhaft strukturieren
ich glaube und das ist eine these die
wir noch diskutieren können dass sich
geistigkeit als auch im längeren aber
auch im weiteren sinne des deutschen
wurde des geistes der sich geistigkeit
vor allem an einem sehr komplexen
begriffen individualität zeigt der sie
unterscheidet von kollektiver also der
nicht jetzt im kontext einer gattung
steht und dieser gattung gehorcht sind
vorgaben der art und gattung zu sagen
dass ich den geistigen das individuum
auch gegen die art stellen kann
gegen das kollektiv ich glaube dass das
ein besonderes merkmal des geistig ist
auch im weiteren sinne des geistes wie
ist der deutsche begriff nein
ja es ist immer noch ein bisschen weiter
wir haben nicht mehr viel zeit ich will
einfach noch mal zu den ameisen com es
fällt uns ziemlich leicht menschen von
pflanzen zu unterscheiden
doch wie steht es mit den tieren als wir
haben bis jetzt nur beliebt die pflanzen
gesprochen wie steht es mit tieren
können wir auch ihnen ein geist zu
ebenso sollten wir sie ähnliche pflanzen
als geistlose lebewesen bezeichnen
betrachtet man die bislang genannten
kriterien muss man offensichtlich
antworten dass die zuschreibung eines
geistes nur möglich ist wenn wir den
tieren und jetzt kommen diese vier
merkmale des geistigen die vorhin
aufgezeigt wurden die wir auf den
letzten sitz schon behandelt hatten wenn
mit den tieren phänomenales bewusstsein
erstens zweitens internationale zu
stellen
drittens sprache und viertens logisches
denken zu schreiben können je nach
standpunkt könnte man fordern dass nur
eines dieser kriterien minimalforderung
oder alle vier kriterien maximal
forderung erfüllt sein müssen natürlich
ist auch noch so eine mischform denkbar
dass also bestimmte kombination
vorliegen müssen eine solche forderung
wirft indessen eine reihe von problemen
auf also hier haben sie jetzt mal vier
merkmale des geistigen und ich glaube
dass man dem durchaus zustimmen kann ich
persönlich mir fehlt hier noch so diese
aspekte individualität aber vielleicht
geht ja auch einher mit diesen
phänomenen das können wir noch ein
bisschen mehr klären und jetzt kommt
eben dieses mythologische problem auf
dass wir auch schon zu sprechen gekommen
sind jetzt auch mal vor dass ersten
schwierigste problem ist methodologische
art wie können wir überhaupt feststellen
ob tiere eines oder alles hier kriterien
erfüllen
nehmen wir einmal an wir könnten uns
darauf einigen dass tiere mindestens
über phänomenales bewusstsein verfügen
müssen wie könnten wir feststellen oder
überprüfen ob sie dieses bewusstsein
haben offensichtlich können wir nur an
uns selbst feststellen
es ist ein bestimmtes wahrnehmungs und
empfindung des erlebnis zu haben
wir können aber nicht beschreiben um ein
berühmtes beispiel von thomson regel zu
zitieren
wie es für eine fledermaus ist eine
fledermaus zu sein
oder genauer gesagt wie es sich für eine
fledermaus anfühlt in einem bestimmten
wahrnehmungs zustand seien und dadurch
ein bestimmtes phänomenales bewusstsein
zu haben aufgrund einer physiologischen
und neurologischen analyse des
wahrnehmungs apparates von fledermäusen
können wir höchstens hypothesen darüber
aufstellen wie aus unserer sicht
betrachtet fledermäuse ein phänomenales
bewusstsein haben könnte aber damit
gewinnen wir höchstens so etwas wie eine
außensicht auf die innenwelt der
fledermäuse umwelt selbst ist uns
prinzipiell
umzugehen das wäre jetzt natürlich
wieder wasser auf die mühlen derjenigen
vertreter die sagen aber da könnte doch
was geistige sein wir können es eben nur
prinzipien nicht wissen
da muss man dann eben ergänzend zu
diesen thesen wie sie in diesem text
vorkommen auf dieser unterlage
sparsamkeit verweisen die doch immer
eigentlich beachtet werden sollte und
zuletzt lese ich noch dieses zitat vor
weil das uns wieder zum anfang unserer
sitzung bringt mit den affen
doch ist es tatsächlich so einfach
kriterien von außen anzuwenden
betrachten wir das kriterium der
sprachfähigkeit jetzt kommt empirische
forschungen mit menschenaffen haben
gezeigt dass diese tiere eine
gebärdensprache und zwar war das dass
diese gebärdensprache verhört gehörlose
bis zu einem gewissen grad lernen können
und in der lage sind auf fragen
angemessen zu reagieren heißt dies dass
sie tatsächlich über eine sprache
verfügen
die antwort auf diese frage ist sehr
umstritten einige prima theologen
vertreten in der tat die ansicht dass
affen über eine genuine sprache verfügen
und damit eines der kriterien für
geistes zu schreiben erfüllen
andere behaupten die angebliche
sprachbeherrschung seien rein
konditioniertes verhalten die affen
seien mit hilfe bestimmter anreiz
einfach dazu trainiert worden bestimmte
zeichen zu geben
dieses verhalten unterscheidet sich
nicht wesentlich von jenem
konditionierten ratten die in bestimmten
situationen eine taste drücken um
nahrung zu erhalten wie der andere
forscher verweisen darauf hin dass die
iaaf nur ein begrenztes repertoire von
zeichen in immer gleicher weise
verwenden jedoch nicht der lage sind die
gegebenen zeigen zwar ihre variieren und
neu zu kombinieren das haben wir auch
gesprochen
angesichts dieser mangelnde fähigkeit zu
kreativem sprachgebrauch könne nicht von
einer eigentlichen sprachbeherrschung
gesprochen werden schließlich werden
einige forscher ein dass das bloße
verwenden isolierter zeichen noch kein
sprachgebrauch darstelle
erst wenn ein lebewesen fähig seine
syntaktische struktur zu erfassen könne
man ihm eine sprache zu schreiben
letzte frage bevor wir aufhören das ist
eine sehr taktische struktur der sprache
wie kann man sie erfassen die muss man
sie erfassen können woran müsste sich
das zeigen diese
taktische sprachverständnis dass man
jetzt vielleicht noch von den bloßen
anwendungs für anwendungs gebrauch von
zeichen unterscheiden muss
was ist das taktisch genau also dass man
nicht nur bestimmte zeichen irgendwie
verwendet weil das waren jetzt isolierte
zeichen die dieser affe verwendet hatte
also praktisch isolierte termini die
jetzt beliebig kombiniert werden können
dass eine sprache noch nicht größere
feinstruktur hat eine syntax als
einsatzdauer dass man nicht nur diese
zeichen jetzt verwendet sondern dass es
darauf kommt in welcher reihenfolge
ordnung diese zeichen verwendet werden
und je nach kombination auch wenn es
dieselben zeichen sind verschiedene
bedeutung ergeben also drei wörter wie
apfelbaum und holz können je nachdem wie
wir in welcher reihenfolge wie diese
begriffe verwenden unterschiedliches
bedeuten und das ist jetzt sicherlich
hier bei dieser gebärdensprache von
diesem affe noch nicht auch noch nicht
berücksichtigt worden
das wäre natürlich ein sehr sehr
anspruchsvoller begriff von sprache da
auch eine syntax und semantik hätten wir
das schreiben einer kurzen ansprache hat
immer syntax und satzbau und eine
semantik semantik ist die
bedeutungsschwere das hätte man mit
diesen zeichen dieses zeichen bedeutet
dass einzelne isoliert die syntax der
kombination der zeichen und semantik und
syntax sind nicht so streng getrennt
sondern sie haben sie interferieren also
je nach satzbau wird auch wer andere
bedeutung erzielt unter umständen und
das scheint hier jedenfalls nur auf die
semantik beschränkt zu sein dieser
sprach bild und eine sehr anspruchsvolle
sprache hat immer semantik und syntax
sie hat sogar noch eine pragmatik das
wissen sie alle wenn sie sprach
literatur kultur steht letzte frage noch
die grammatik auch noch eine
rechtschreibung
potenz tenz diese pensionen ja zur zeit
bewusst sein die auch sprachlich ist ja
also ich finde auch dass man zum geistig
noch so was wie zeitlos zu erzählen
könnte wahrscheinlich ist in diesem
sprach begriff den die autoren
zugrundelegung des zeit bewusstsein
schon inkludiert oder im
selbstbewusstseins begriff aber zeit ist
auch noch ein guter punkt den wir
berücksichtigen müssen so in der
nächsten sitzung lesen wir diesen text
weiter und ich schicke ihnen den ersten
historischen text den wir auch gemeinsam
lesen wollen und mal schauen wollen wie
die historischen autoren mit diesen
fragen die wir jetzt systematisch
geklärt haben umgegangen sind und ob die
historischen autos vielleicht noch
weitere interessante gedanken geäußert
hatten die wir selbst heutigen gar nicht
mehr auf dem schirm h weil sie
vielleicht den tieren näher standen oder
weiter entfernt standen als wir soll zu
tages- und bis zur nächsten sitzung